President Biden participated in two
leaders sessions of the summit one on
the African Union's agenda 2063 plan to
transform the continent over the next 50
years and one on ensuring food security
once again Biden's message was of
Equitable development Mutual success and
U.S investment over the next three years
working in close cooperation with the
United States Congress
we plan to commit 55 billion dollars in
Africa to advance the priorities we
share
and and to support the agenda 2063
however when asked U.S government
officials were unable to provide a
breakdown of how the figure of 55
billion dollars was arrived at or how
the Biden Administration intends to get
Congress to approve that sum the
president of the African Union welcomed
the US's renewed commitment to Africa
but called for Washington to end its
economic sanctions on Zimbabwe and its
plans to sanction other African
countries via the so-called malign
Russian activities in Africa act still
working its way through Congress
this bill with its sanctions which
targets a whole continent is the first
in international relations Africa is
asking why such a bill exists and why is
Africa targeted at least outwardly the
U.S has changed its tone at the summit
not publicly hectoring African nations
about decisions Washington doesn't agree
with but there is still skepticism about
whether anything really is different the
problem isn't what they're saying
they're saying all the right things the
problem is they're not doing anything
differently they're still focusing more
on on you know open societies on values
rather than on increasing Investments
and and sort of a more concrete
approach to encouraging businesses to
invest in the region and even as the
Biden Administration talks of democracy
and human rights it was notable that the
only African leader to get an honor
guard was the Egyptian president who
oversees a government not noted for its
Democratic Values the U.S sees itself as
the world's indispensable Nation but
there's little patience for that sort of
talk here there are simply too many
other countries willing to do business
with Africa who don't demand economic
and political obedience
Al Jazeera Washington